bonsoir bonsoir vous l'aviez dit je
pense à votre cocus il y a quelques
jours j'ai dit j'ai été blessé vous avez
vraiment été blessé par quoi exactement
par certains propos qui ont été tenus
lorsque lorsqu'on dit que l'immigration
non francophone peut être une menace
pour la nation québécoise moi monsieur
voilà ce que je suis arrivé ici j'avais
8 ans je parlais vraiment de français ou
d'anglais mes parents ils parlaient pas
non plus ils ont étudié ils ont
travaillé fort mon père faisait du
ménage de mes autres mots j'allais
l'aider à fait l'équivalence ça fait son
doctory était professeur université donc
je peux pas concevoir qu'on puisse
considérer mon père ma mère qui était
professeur université au moins qui
essaient de faire de mon mieux ici comme
une menace donc vous dites le lien que
l'on fait continuellement entre
l'immigration non francophone et la
survie du français vous dites attention
là parce que oui il y a des transferts
linguistiques vers l'anglais alors vous
pouvez pas nier ça au Québec à tous les
pouvoirs actuellement vous savez Québec
peut choisir 28% de tous les immigrants
qui rentrent au Canada vous avez environ
immigrants qui rentrent par année donc
Québec peut choisir 112 mm il peut et
après 50 l'autre 72 il pourrait le
choisir demain matin et il parlerait
tous 100% français il y a pas besoin de
pouvoir il y a pas besoin de demander
quoi que ce soit il peut le faire mais
le Québec vous répond d'abord je veux
revenir sur la blessure parce qu'on a eu
beaucoup de courriel aussi des gens dans
la grande région de Montréal qui d'abord
le fait de pas travailler puis ça
revient beaucoup vous vous dites qu'on
peut accueillir mettons 80 000
immigrants là c'était le seuil le plus
élevé dans la campagne québécoise et les
francisés à peu près tous ils pourraient
tous être français il parle il pourrait
tous parler français en arrivant le
Québec dispose déjà en vertu de
l'entente Québec Canada de ce pouvoir là
il y a à peu près facilement le dos mais
je crois demain matin le Québec pourrait
faire rentrer facilement le dôme
d'immigrants qui fait la tractuellement
et tous et des francophones
sans demander quoi que ce soit qui que
ce soit alors quand monsieur Legault
vous dit j'ai besoin de tous les
pouvoirs en immigration là ils ont
effectivement une partie des pouvoirs
pour l'immigration régulière ils veulent
la réunification familiale que vous avez
le fédéral et ils veulent plus de
contrôle sur l'immigration temporaire
oui ça c'est beaucoup plus de monde
l'immigration temporaire qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ce précisément le sur
ces deux points là mais les deux seuls
endroits où le fédéral à son mot à dire
c'est les réfugiés choisis par le Canada
à peu près 2500 personnes par année et
la réunification familiale à laquelle
vous faites référence voilà malin 10000
11000 personnes pas plus c'est pas ça
qui remet en question la survie de la
nation québécoise ni le fait français si
10 belles personnes par année mais
qu'est-ce que ça changerait si c'est pas
le fédéral que j'ai choisi si c'était
Québec est-ce que ça serait donc que des
gens qui parlent déjà français ça veut
dire que si moi j'ai le malade dans mon
amour avec une italienne ou avec une
Grecque
personne prépare chez nous non la
réunification familiale me sera elle est
basée sur l'amour sur les liens qui
naissent ces personnes n'ont pas sur la
langue et d'ailleurs il y en a déjà
beaucoup qui parle de français en
arrivant donc pour toutes ces raisons-là
vous dites monsieur Lego peut répéter et
son gouvernement peut répéter mais on ne
bougera pas sur les pouvoirs qui
demeurent aux fédéral mais c'est encore
une fois Québec a tous les pouvoirs
actuellement et je vois pas qu'est-ce
que ça changerait encore une fois si
la question familiale serait et se le
dit sur l'immigration temporelle mais
certificat il faut il ait choisissent
ils ont leur mot à dire là-dessus aussi
c'est pas nous qui les imposons dans
chaque cas ils vous disent oui mais
c'est pas assez efficace les étudiants
africains arrivent pas puis on arrive
pas à les faire venir assez vite puis
nous ça serait plus efficace vous
répondez quoi c'est vrai c'est pas assez
efficace ni du côté d'Ottawa ni du côté
du Québec on peut faire mieux que à quoi
est-ce que Valentin ou la rapidité d'un
dossier mais en péril le fait français
il y a une nuance vous faire attention
lorsqu'on arrive avec le débat il y a
c'est amalgame là il trouve facile
et
moi l'immigration puis monsieur Roy
l'immigration c'est déjà c'est des
hommes c'est des femmes c'est des
enfants qui des pays dans des conditions
souvent horribles très difficiles qui
arrivent ici pour bâtir une vie
meilleure et qui contribue
fondamentalement à la société québécoise
vous dites et c'est effectivement le
chiffre aux fédéral on cible à peu près
420 000 même plus que ça mais disons que
420 000 pour la discussion pour que le
Québec conserve sa part dans la
Fédération il faudrait que le Québec
accueille à peu près 100 000 à peu près
23% du 400000 à peu près à peu près
100000 au Québec ça semble faire
consensus que ce serait trop ce serait
trop parce qu'il pourrait avoir un
danger pour la langue française vous
vous dites c'est une fausse équation
mais monsieur rock Québec actuellement
accueille des milliers d'immigrants qui
sont pas francophones Québec décède
lui-même de prendre des francophones
francophones c'est son choix c'est très
bien mais les gens qui l'accueillent
déjà ils pourraient être ça pour ça
francophone il excédent ce qu'on va
chercher de plus pour être 100%
francophone aussi Québec détient ce
pouvoir là Monsieur il était important
parce qu'il faut promouvoir le faire
français c'est notre langue on l'aime il
faut la défendre l'état péril le Canada
est majoritairement l'Amérique du Nord
alors il faut il faut avoir ces outils
aménaux et Québec donc on peut selon
vous accueillir 100 000 immigrants et ne
pas mettre en danger le caractère
français ça dépend ça dépend encore une
fois si vous accueillez 5000
francophones il parle déjà français donc
la question c'est pas possible c'est
mais qui a l'accueille moins que la
cueille plus il y a d'une part la
capacité de Québec d'accueillir beaucoup
plus immigrants déjà francophones et
Ottawa contribue pour 700 millions par
année donc à peu près le double du
budget actuel de Québec pour la
francisation donc vous êtes le
lieutenant politique du Québec Pablo
Rodriguez et quand vous entend vous avez
entendu tout au long de la campagne
comme moi le Québec réclamait ça et
d'ailleurs c'est à peu près tous les
partis réclamaient ça tous les pouvoirs
en immigration pour vous c'est ça fait
même pas de sens
je vois pas tout à fait la logique dans
la mesure où Québec fait entrer un
nombre immigrants bien dans cette sa
capacité
et que en même temps il a cette capacité
de choisir des erreurs
qui parlent français ça pour ça d'un
truc
mais donc
si je vous suis
que monsieur Legault le demande 10 20 30
fois votre patron monsieur Trudeau
vous-même les gens ne changent il y aura
pas un Jota de progrès dans ce dossier
là je vais vous le dire autrement quelle
nation souveraine comme le Canada quel
pays
peut céder entièrement à une de ces
parties le choix des personnes qui vont
arriver qui va avoir son propre
passeport et sa propre citoyenneté ça
existe pas dans le monde ça existe pas
et encore une fois il faut le défendre
de faire face il faut défendre le
français mais Québec à la capacité de
faire venir plus immigrants et qui soit
100% francophone vous dites presque à
monsieur Legault si vous voulez faire ça
soyez souverains faites le
référendums en immigration la seule
façon c'est d'avoir la souveraineté
entière ce que vous dites ce que je dis
c'est que ça fonctionne bien c'est une
fédération où le Québec bénéficie d'une
attente particulière très bénéfique
d'ailleurs les autres provinces
voudraient avoir la même attente que
Québec l'argent qu'on donne au Québec à
francisation
pour l'apprentissage de langue et à peu
près la somme équivalente de toutes les
autres provinces du pays je suis pas
certain que en fait je suis certain que
voudrait pas réouvrir cette entente là
parce qu'il est avantageux et tant mieux
s'il est avantageux pour nous je le dis
comme québécois tant mieux pour nous sur
la jupe politique là on s'en va où avec
ce débat je sais pas c'est pas c'est pas
à moi de définir les paramètres de base
du débat moi je vous dis
tels les choses telles qu'elles sont
c'est-à-dire cette capacité de Québec de
faire venir plus immigrants qui soient
tous francophones moi je veux plus de
monde qui parle plus français je veux
plus de musique en français je suis plus
de séries en français je peux je fais ma
phrase ce soir plus mais vous avez
entendu comme moi sans arrêt puis j'ai
l'air de poser toujours la même question
nous avons entendu sans arrêt le premier
ministre du Québec dire c'est pas
possible puis même lui il veut plafonner
à 5 ans d'autres voulaient monter à 80
disent pas possible parce que dans la
réalité des choses si on monte trop
forcément il va avoir trop de gens à
franciser pour n'est pas capable des
Français si vous faites rentrer 70 000
personnes qui sont déjà francophones
vous en avez combien la France ici 0
c'est possible de faire venir 70 000
Québec pourrait augmenter ses chiffres
et à travers c'est pas simple c'est
compliqué parce qu'évidemment il y a
beaucoup plus de gens qui parlent
anglais ou d'autres langues que le
français mais est-ce que c'est possible
probablement ça Québec de voir nous on
va les appuyer du début jusqu'à la fin
puis est-ce qu'on peut travailler mieux
que collectivement absolument donc un
terminal la négociation sera pas très
longue
je vois pas tout à fait ce qui a négocié
si Québec avant même d'essayer de
chercher du pouvoir peut à l'intérieur
de ses propres pouvoirs qui sont énormes
allez chercher plus de monde plus de
francophones
on va suivre ça merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous voir vous ça reprend la
semaine prochaine
Ottawa ouais bonne rentrée merci
beaucoup merci à vous au revoir